that real solid man of rock and roll
Little Richard and mom told Sally born
as Richard Wayne Penniman boy from
America's Deep South Georgia with the
world knows and remembers as Little
Richard one of the founding fathers of
rock and roll his flamboyant style of
playing the piano and distinctive stage
presence was a fine blend of his gospel
roots and the blues to create something
electric Little Richard exploded onto
the scene with his first hit single in
1955
tutti-frutti whose lyrics were
considered so racy that it had to be
censored it sold a million copies over
the air and has been described as the
one record that changed the world of
music in the u.s. was a time when black
and white Americans was segregated but
little Rich's music broke that racial
divide both on the dance floor and on
the Billboard charts he sold more than
30 million records worldwide and
influenced a generation of musicians
from the Beatles to David Bowie Elvis
Presley Prince even formed a band with
Jimi Hendrix but later fired him for
being late for a bus at times in his
life his lifestyles seemed to him to be
at odds with his faith he went on to
study theology selling Bibles and
producing gospel music
but he would keep returning to the world
he knew whelmed reinventing and
relaunching his career in the 1970s he
vanished from the scene for more than a
decade returned with a smash hit and an
entry into the Rock and Roll Hall of
Fame in 1986 part of the first group of
musicians ever to be inducted
[Applause]
he finally won one in 1993 a Lifetime
Achievement Award in 2013
Little Richard announced his retirement
hello rock and roll is the life ever
love you he'll be remembered as a
pioneer an entertainer and an
inspiration who overcame obstacles
throughout his entire life and leaves
behind a rich musical legacy Little
Richard was 87
[Music]